i find it interesting aj that you're
talking about
things when we ask you certain technical
things and you really go to it from an
intuitive standpoint
like you're you're talking about stuff
that's just
like almost observational or gut level
like you know all the technical parts
inside and out but it sounds like a lot
of how you operate
is by pure instinct in some to sense
different
almost like in in battle like you're on
the front line or something that's what
it feels like sometimes
especially action sequences where
you literally are and you know simulated
battle but um
i think part of that is just my style as
a cinematographer you know again as i
said before this is not always the case
for some other dps i don't know what the
other dp's process
is because i'm not that person i didn't
grow up
wanting to be a dp even though i am one
now
i didn't go into this business wanting
to be a cinematographer
i want to be a filmmaker so i think
about things
a little bit differently i'm not so
concerned
with the technical aspect of things i am
concerned with it on a
uh almost autonomous level like
i'm aware of the camera's settings at
all times i'm aware of how
well that take was if it was overexposed
if the light was in the background was
too bright or something like that
i know those things as i'm watching the
footage but that's not the important
thing to me because
that's not the important thing for an
audience either if you're going to the
movie you don't care about that
you care about what's happening in the
story and you want to remain
you want to keep your suspension of
disbelief going
and so when i'm shooting a film i'm
trying to do that
all the time i don't
i learned pretty early on that a small
technical flaw
of some kind is generally going to be
overlooked by an
average audience member so i i took some
of the pressure off myself
to be perfect technically it's really
not what it's all about
it's okay to be a little bit off or it's
okay to have like
a small hiccup here and there you know
whether something's over exposed too
slight too much or whether you were just
a little off in the focus on that pool
you know sometimes that stuff actually
works in the middle of a scene
if it's organic and it's done in a way
that
people will assume it was done on
purpose
so if you treat it almost like
i think you have to achieve a level of
technical expertise to get to this point
or you can start thinking about other
things
it's like driving a car for the first
time at first you're like okay the fee
my feet are on the gas pedal
all right okay there's the brake right
here and then okay the radio okay my
mirrors are set correctly
like you're nervous about that when you
first started having a car but after a
while you're looking
three or four miles down the horizon to
see what's going on you don't even look
at the road in front of you
and they've done studies on this where
people's eyes are tracked as a young
driver and their eyes are going left and
right and up and down and
to the gauges and that's why people get
in accidents when they're 15 16 17 years
old
it's because their eyes are so nervous
and focused on all the different
technical details around them they lose
track of what's weight down the road in
front of them
and to me as a cinematographer i'm
looking down the road making sure that
the film is
on the right path and not going down
some dead end somewhere having a problem
story wise because it's something i'm
doing so i guess it's
the same way like after a while you get
experienced enough with these cameras
and eight rigs
and they're all very similar anymore i
mean it's very
hard pressed to be challenged with
settings in a camera anymore i mean
it's a brand new camera coming out okay
that's cool i'll check it out i'll see
what it's capable of
i can tell pretty quickly based on the
specs and based on some of the
you know the footage that they post from
nab and things like that
what the camera is capable of where its
strengths and weaknesses are
and what kind of uses you can get out of
it
so all that technical stuff i try to do
early on in the process
process like pre-production i'm choosing
the camera the lenses
the lighting style and i get a lot of
this stuff from the director if the
director asks me
to he you know our director is inspired
by a certain lighting style
one time a director told me he's super
big fan of dave adventure films
wants me to light things similar
obviously provide her known my own flair
to it but
be similar to these images and he
provided me some images from a dave
fincher film
i know dave fincher likes a lot of soft
overhead lighting so i
got my package to be in my lighting
package accordingly
and i explained that to my gaffer
accordingly but once i have that
knowledge and that
information in their head i can send
them off and say
you know what to do here we've talked
about it and now i can focus on the more
important thing which is
making a good film and making good film
isn't always
making a perfectly technical good film
and sometimes
more about getting on that one
opportunity you have to get it
especially in a low budget level where
sometimes you have to be able to just
grab a camera
and go shoot something that wasn't
planned like that
like sometimes i'll be shooting a movie
in mexico we have
12 minutes to get this action scene on
the street done and there's a car
driving up and people running
and you know complicated
coordination of things happening and if
you can achieve those
high pressure situation
the only way to do that is actually to
have that technical kind of base
already built up so that you're not
worried about the setting if you're
sitting there fiddling with the camera
in the moment you're going to miss it
so i think because i've been doing this
for like 10 years now
professionally it's kind of something
technical stuff is just not it doesn't
excite me as much i'm not interested in
the cameras and the lenses and
i like making those decisions early on
but once i have those decisions made
it's just kind of like
let's choose from this toolbox that
we've built for this film for what's
next in the scene instead of being like
okay
you know doing the math and all that
stuff
i could be a weird cinematographer
because i don't like those things but
this is my style you know it reminds me
of speaking of psychology that the
maslow's uh
it was a hierarchy of needs so you have
security safety
shelter you know all that here and once
that's
you know met then you can go to these
other like
far out you know self-acceptance or you
know all these different things it
sounds like the same thing
for the filmmaking once you have you
know the iso and all these different
things correct
then you can go to other realms with it
and really
yeah i think you can also start breaking
rules you can start taking the rules
that you know
and going i don't really like this rule
right now it doesn't
work for me in the scene i want to break
this rule and i have a reason for it
and you can choose to go crazy like i
remember
on lost time i shot a scene at 12
800 iso and it turned out
really cool looking because i was like i
want to see what this camera can do at
that level and
also i'm on an alien spacecraft
i feel like it would be a totally
different experience
to a human and in my mind there's other
light sources going on there's a whole
other spectrum of light maybe that the
alien can see
so you're getting blasted in my mind
with light
and i wanted to have a viewer experience
that to a certain extent
through the camera and if that means i
pushed the camera to the limit or i
pushed it past its limit
then that's what i had to do for the
scene but i just did it because i wanted
to do it not because i
thought oh well this you know the rule
tells me i got to
shoot this iso for you know this type of
scene i just i've
worked with the camera so many times i
just got bored of doing it all
the right way i just wanted to do it the
way i wanted to do
you